[Music]
i'm sorry that first gets through my
throat you almost choked him to death oh
good did it himself this week we've got
fun police halloween display and thong
jeans ooh did you say fun bonkins wait
fun play at tonk jeans is where it had
me i'm like no
did you say fun please
it's like the most mundane thing at all
did you say an apple
all i was trying to do is just clarify
what i heard not that it was outlandish
oh i see what you say i [ __ ] up yeah
tag it away
tiffany okay
for our first story the fun police this
man in canada
got a fine for singing too loudly in his
car
maybe his singing [ __ ] song
he got a 149 dollar fine
whose ears did he make bleed
you know it really depends though i
think that people wouldn't be so
outraged depending on if they could hear
him sing or the hour yeah oh that's
right i forgot about time and people
sleep morning okay
three a.m i don't know when i hear
people sing in their car and i see them
seeing their brains out it makes me
really happy though
i'm like awesome they're having the time
of their life yeah i can't hear yeah i
usually can't hear what does it look
like what does it look like
and then usually i'm like awesome
they're having the time of their life
that's true i haven't seen very many
people do it because i've seen the ones
where they're like and then you pull up
and they're like
that's me
yeah
that's how you gotta get your windows 10
yeah i like seeing people rapping too
especially like a person that you
wouldn't imagine that they'd be into the
type of rapping because i could see them
going nerdy white boy like a police
officer
[Laughter]
no wait [ __ ] the police i think this has
a batch oh i'll take that
yeah i don't like it when i see uh
police officers text to drive by the way
oh
those [ __ ] you know it's like
you're above the law now what [ __ ] do
you think you are like i want to get a
badge like just make a paper mache one
like this and come out what what just
make that same noise citizens
texting and driving [ __ ] write
yourself a ticket
you should come up behind them
have you guys seen the videos of people
pulling over police officers yeah
there's a youtube channel what do you
have to do you got to tailgate them
until they're like what the [ __ ] this
guy doing they just follow them until
they pull over or like yeah is this ever
in l.a because i feel like la cops yeah
yeah no there's there's la people that
go up to cops and then chase them to
their like
like station and then they just record
them and they're like sir why is it okay
for you to go 100 miles per hour
and not us and he's like well you don't
know if i had important things to do he
goes i think you're just late for work
are they minorities that are doing it i
think the guy that was recording that
one was mexican yes and then there's
this other one where uh uh like a semi
truck he he saw that a cop was going
like this and he was swerving so he
pulled the cop over and then the cop
started lecturing him and he was like
but i saw you on your phone and you were
swerving and that wasn't that wasn't you
know safe and i was like damn these guys
are they're brave dude because i'm
thinking i'm getting my teeth knocked in
if i say that [ __ ] i'm getting arrested
100 year girl
dude i still got in harassed lottery
parks i'm like why i'm a girl well how
are you how are you harassed yeah
there's all types of yeah was it
essentially harassed no no no no it
wasn't this
was just drive basically all i did was i
was driving like at maybe 10 or 11. he
pulls me over where are you going i'm
like what like to go get gas oh at this
hour i'm like did you do this no i was
wearing a hoodie with the hood on it
that's why you're [ __ ] up you had a
hoodie on who drives with the hoodie on
why pull me over because you look like a
unabomber yeah that's that's like
criminal stereotype number one i was
wearing makeup uh it doesn't mexican
with a hoodie but when they pulled you
off over they didn't know that they just
see a hoodie a hoodie looks androgynous
as [ __ ] wait so then just because
someone's wearing a hoodie it makes it
okay to pull someone over no it doesn't
so it's like cop 101. racial profiling
right so when you profile someone you're
like wait okay is there weight in the
pants if there's weight in the patch
there's probably a gun in the pants so
they have to examine the physical
situation so
no it's not but i'm just saying they
profile people immediately profiling
yeah profiling and racial profiling is
one of the is one of them yes but
there's multiple types of profiling and
so looking at articles of clothing
that's one of the first things if you
have a hoodie yeah i was wearing a cute
style though where the hair was still
popping out it wasn't like like
not like this like the cute
talking about like the girl style like
it's cute i had like a fur brim he just
sucked that flirting oh yeah that's what
i was trying to do and i got a ticket
after i flirted maybe you suck at
flirting never i've never seen this
flirting happen none of it you didn't
get you oh wait i didn't no no i didn't
flirt he flirted that i [ __ ] up see
you're not all right you're just being
sexually harassed that's not the same
whatever you didn't harass back yeah
anyways that's weird should i flash your
dick it would have stopped that
conversation quick
i'm ready for a party officer
bam and he's like i like that oh then
you're [ __ ] i am [ __ ] i don't have
to travel to thailand i got one right
here woman in the face man in the pants
mm-hmm so this man here this canadian
man his name is telfek talfik
and so this is toxic
that's not his name that's a cool name
it's spelled t-a-o-u-f-i-k
towel
t-a-o-u-p-a-o-u
however you want us
what about mr t mr t he was listening to
this song
see the everybody you have to like
elevate the voice there man he's
probably screaming at the top of his
[ __ ] lungs
if that ranges
then if he's screaming it
no you can't
you can't sing that in key
without yeah you can't do it and the
energy behind it too for real so then he
got pulled over and so well initially
like everybody danced now
you need that energy when the cops are
trying to pull them over he thought that
they just wanted to pass them by so he
just moved over to the side and then
that's when they wanted the speaker like
can you please pull over and so he
pulled over her hands down stop voguing
everybody
and then that's when four police
officers came four two men on each side
four police tank this is canada too so i
think they just haven't arrested anybody
in three years and they just needed to
do something come on come on come on
let's go we gotta arrest somebody
[ __ ] out of the car what was he wearing
was he wearing that hoodie i'm not sure
what he was wearing a hoodie with makeup
and the fur brim
so then they asked him uh if he was
screaming or if anyone in the car was
screaming he was like no he's just
singing but they still gave him a thing
for help was there a woman in distress
in your car no that was just me singing
was there a dying dog in your car yeah
according to montreal by law
a quote to cause disorder by screaming
violates peace and tranquility and can
be punishable by fine of 50 to eight to
one thousand dollars for first offense
first of all dude i would be so [ __ ]
offended yeah true they classified my
singing as screaming like who the [ __ ]
are you simon cowell
like if somebody literally gave me a
ticket because they classified my
beautiful voice as screaming that's
discrimination but this song you're kind
of screaming it though like but i'm
saying the fact that they said that no
that was screaming i'll be like no i was
singing and [ __ ] you i'm good and they
have a law
that
you get fined for screaming that's
disturbing the peace what the hell
exactly so now he's gonna he's planning
on contesting it so he has to wait
baseball umpires must have a [ __ ]
hefty fine i could just picture him in
court he goes excuse me this is my only
defense
oh man he's
you're innocent and then the [ __ ]
bellagio water show starts
and it's in slow motion as the cop gets
carried away what did it do
all four of them all four of them
he was screaming
yeah but apparently his wife was like
well if it was for singing i would have
given you a ticket for three hundred
dollars damn
his wife is a [ __ ] [ __ ]
she was kidding obviously wife's got
jokes you don't joke about that the
wives jokes are always just
[ __ ] on the husbands
that's so funny that's their punchline
no creativity i guarantee you though
those are one of those jokes though it's
like the whole world's like but that
guy's kind of like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
that's the thing he loves doing and then
she knows that if she makes fun of him
for it yeah it hurts him and slices his
ass oh yeah i know it yeah we do that on
purpose all right so for our next story
there's this couple in new jersey
that decorated their home
with like a halloween display because
they love halloween they were getting
into the spirit
but a lot of their neighbors didn't like
this halloween display and they even
called the cops on them oh my god what
up looks too real
this is the decision oh [ __ ] oh no i
used to have that car that's a toyota
supra i completely take back my
statement what i said before that is
[ __ ] crazy that is pretty [ __ ]
crazy though it was like a skeleton
being hung like from the party store
that's a crime scene that that looks
like a [ __ ] crime it is yeah it's an
entire crime scene
whoever made this
do you guys want to sell your car
because i really want my old car back it
burned down that one burned two oh
what's up with you and white cars
burning i had it was like gray though
silver or gray right yeah that one was a
silver car it was silver after it got
burned down yeah so then they're just
saying like
the neighbors are just
yeah that's not a decor decoration yeah
it's not christmas lights yeah like half
and half of the opinion one half is
saying like oh it's just halloween who
cares like this is awesome you should
add more to it and then the other half
is like whoa it's a little too real it
does look hella realistic and i think
it's
it's exactly in the middle i think
instead of like ratting out the neighbor
all they really need to do is maybe have
one happy halloween sign well this is
the front of their home something they
have like other halloween displays wait
what wait why is it so extreme well
that's what i'm saying there's no
that connection so [ __ ] like regular
and basic not even regular this is
really crappy
okay i thought it was the least amount
of effort i've ever seen anybody
decorate their house
over here and then they did this yeah a
big disconnect i hired quentin tarantino
just to do that part it's too real you
know what it means i added like a sign
near it trying to say like adding story
or context to the scene which is like a
zombie apocalypse and they're saying
that the only thing they could do is
grab this car and then run over a zombie
so this is oh
it doesn't even look like us it looks
like a human being i mean i'm a little
desensitized but i actually have a
friend in college actually died like
this but he got smashed into a light
pole so if i saw this in person i
probably feel a little weird about it
you know what i mean so
that's a little bit too real and this is
something that actually legit happens
like on a regular basis like a lot of
people are saying it was like it's a
little too far yeah it's probably about
like for the kids on like the kids are
walking home from school and there's no
context and they just see that like oh
[ __ ] that's crazy yeah and some kids
might not even understand it's like what
the [ __ ] is that well according to the
homeowners the kids love this life of
course they do
kids are [ __ ]
mean when he needs yeah add to it it's
just maybe a couple of like isis victims
that are beheaded with like the heads
rolling on the floor because like for me
if this was like a like a statement
saying like don't drink and drive we had
that at our high school minus the blood
in the body yeah we had a car that was
crashed yup yeah i saw that too and it
helps me kind of like wrap my head
around it because the the the the person
i knew in college he died from a drunk
driver so he was just walking home and
wow but it'd be a different story if
that same car had like blood all over
the [ __ ] windshield and then like a
shoe hanging out like i'd be like oh
[ __ ] that's too far i'm more upset about
rest in peace juan [ __ ] breaking a
perfectly good bumper in the front and
they have to take that out well it was
part of the display they did that on
purpose they took the bumper i don't
like how they're treating the toyota
supra because i personally it's a
classic and i think they should be
restoring it not using it as some junk
car
but that's just my opinion you guys
notice like with like cars that that
that's that old that has that specific
type of fabric has a very specific smell
yep all those cards always smell like
[ __ ] mold and sweat antique store
yeah yeah it just all of them smell like
that no matter how well you keep it it
just smells you know what they need to
bring back they need to bring back that
automatic seat belt thing oh
i always wanted to sit in the car with
that
the honda cords had it you still have to
put your lap belt on them technically
but then also i mean this doesn't really
work that well because i've tried like
fighting it and i'm like dude my head's
gonna smash into the windshield easily
and you still want them to come back
yeah because i just they're pretty cool
but bmw's got that thing where they at
least extend it out for you
and you can just do this what they do
where that thing comes out like this
because you know you to usually do this
the bmw thing could come
oh i got the [ __ ] low model then not
mine doesn't do that i never needed to
use a seat belt so i don't know why i
have to do it but i have to do it kids
always use your seatbelt
i just started using it when they made
it a lot same when did they make it a
law i don't remember it 10 years ago
like really 15 years ago we didn't have
to wear seat belts dude i remember
growing up as a kid like in the
passenger seat i never have to wear a
seat belt maybe 20 years ago it was
later on cool thing about seat belts are
though statistically they have
dramatically reduced auto fatalities
like a ridiculous amount so but they
took out all the fun and riding
so do you guys remember being a kid and
then dr uh being able to sit in the back
of a pickup truck while your brother
drives you around town because your
brother doesn't let you sit inside the
[ __ ] truck with them so he leaves you
in the back of the truck with the dogs i
used to ride in the back with the dog
when my dad drove yeah
it was my choice what we do i ghetto
[ __ ] kids like we would uh get like a
surf kind of we would get a tarp and put
in the truck bed and then fill that up
with water and all the neighborhood kids
would jump in there and then the dad
yeah the dad would drive and then step
on the brakes and the [ __ ] kids are
flying all over the place that is some
redneck [ __ ]
that's some hood [ __ ] see we got a lot
of things in common i don't know why we
have to
you know pete inner city people or
rednecks we could all come together it's
the same [ __ ] riding in back of pickups
with making them into pools so for our
last story there's this tokyo fashion
designer who came up with these long
jeans i saw this [ __ ] did you guys see
this honestly it was getting passed
around for a minute wait so it's every
part of the gene except for the part i
love japan oh my god did she go in a
blender like it's like it's like a
it's like a thong oh
i was like an outline of the entire gene
without the actual jean it's all of the
double layered parts the seams are where
all the seams are at it looks pretty
dope though you still got pockets though
i like that 100
i hope somebody in taiwan has those
jeans so mosquito could eat them alive
where would girls wear this
like to an art exhibit music festival
probably during the hospital
like i'd understand if i saw this in the
streets and they were like i paid three
dollars for this i'm like that's worth
it because you literally got three
dollars worth of fabric so it makes
sense however if this ever becomes
popular i guarantee you it's just going
to be worth way more than that yep i was
trying to find out how much they were
going to retail these for but i couldn't
because they're not available yet not
until like next year i mean who knows
you don't even know if it's going to hit
the market either like these fashion
shows so like concept yeah the concept
well they're saying that it'll come out
next year oh yeah yeah i feel like you
can make that at home
they're pretty close right now i feel
like fashion people
are are the best trolls on earth like
some of the costumes that i see
it's better than like burning man
festival and but but the the funnier
part is that they take themselves so
[ __ ] serious that's why they're the
greatest trolls because they yeah and
they believe themselves and then people
follow along that's the crazy part you
know when pharrell came out with that
giant smokey the bear hat yeah and then
now everyone justin bieber yeah everyone
was like laughing at him and then all of
a sudden everyone started buying one
yeah they're crazy the best ones that
highlighted that whole like world was
zoolander with like mugatu and [ __ ]
and he had like his [ __ ] weird ass
hair i was like that's ingenious you
know there is it's like not based on a
real story but there is a uh
israeli agent like a like a cia kind of
style agent that came to the us and his
dream was to be a hairdresser so he's an
assassin
hairdresser he retired from that and
then he became like a hairdresser oh
it's like that adam sandler movie yeah
yeah what's that called yeah
so yeah
did he legit have a six-pack in that
movie or was that digitally put there
maybe he worked out just for that scene
what a hard worker hey guys thanks for
watching the last episode did you love
it i know you did but guess what you can
also follow us on our personal social
media accounts with the links in the
description box below so go follow all
of us
now to watch more videos check them out
up there